اجراءات عقابيه جديده تنتظر ايران حيث
تتصاعد الدعوات الاوروبيه لتصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه فما عزمي
بريطانيا ادراجها لحرس الثوري على قوائم
المنظمات الارهابيه
تتزايد المطالب نفسها في المانيا تحركات
حديثه من برلمانيين المان للضغط على
الحكومه لتصنيف الحرس الثوري كم منظمه
ارهابيه للالتحاق بدول ابرزها امريكا في
هذا السياق
الدعوات المؤيده لهذه الخطوه ترى في
الحارس الثوري دورا مهما في قمع
الاحتجاجات المستمره في ايران وكجراء
لمعاقبه النظام في ايران على دوره في
الحرب باوكرانيا حضر الحارس الثوري يعني
ان اي انتماء للمجموعه او حضور اجتماعاته
او حمله شعاراته في الاماكن العامه او
التشجيعه على دعم انشطته يعاقب عليها
بالقانون دعوات اخرى تبدو اكثر جديه في
لندن حيث تستعد حكومه ريشي سوناك لتصنيف
الحارس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه في غضون
اسابيع بعد عشر مؤامرات لخطف او قتل اشخاص
في بريطانيا العمل الماضي وفقا صحيفه
التلغرافيا البريطانيه رشا خياط العربيه